everything cool with you and Taylor
super all because they're just homeless
yeah well according to Justin Bieber he
and Taylor Swift are homies they always
been cool with her yeah that's good man
all right
yeah he says he's not interested in the
drama this is the first time Bieber has
talked about Taylor since he poked fun
at her banana LASIK surgery moment what
do we do with this no it doesn't have my
head yeah this also comes after all the
well drama that came out of Bieber's
manager Scooter Braun buying Taylor's
old label Big Machine Records which
includes all her master recordings how
did you find out I found out when it was
online like when it hit the news
I couldn't believe who he sold it to at
the time Bieber involved himself by
posting this long message on Instagram
in part quote neither scooter or I have
anything negative to say about you we
truly want the best for you since then
taylor has promised to re-record all her
old songs in 2020 I think that artists
deserve to own their work starting
November 2020 so next year I can record
albums 1 through 5 all over again so
[Applause]
about it but back to Bieber and his
relationship with Taylor the two were
actually homies back in the day
Bieber even Punk'd Taylor hey you just
got to remember that so what do we think
guys half Taylor and Justin squashed the
beef everything cool with you and Taylor
super all together just homeless yeah or
is this Justin's way of wanting to
squash the beef let me know and for all
the latest on Taylor and Justin keep it
locked to all things et until next time
I'm Katie Krauss and I will see you next
time
[Music]